Two years ago or whatever it is,
maybe
you don't want you to face on.
And Great Clinical thinkers of the 20th century,
you know,
some centers will be surprised is that tried to take what I'm ready to is still
proudly useful.
You know,
I'm not taking credit and bad credit for that red [inaudible] work of many,
many extraordinary awful.
It's held meetings about,
they say I was having a rough time,
one thing or another and I started,
you know,
formulating a vision for my life and I'm starting to try to tell it to them more
and take more responsibility and things are way there.
And thank you.
And so we got that.
Do you ask people what I want for my birthday?
Well,
this is curt now.
Our next like a dozen people.
And what paypal was the finger?
Very happy with the counter.
What I've been doing it the device and how [inaudible]
feminism
[inaudible] or on slips
[inaudible] form because
I do the crowd sitting here.
We [inaudible].
So,
um,
and so here's the theory and but what,
that's not the boring,
but here's the point will be visual that they're happy,
encouraged.
I know I'm,
you're going to call home because I see it.
I'm Pena and ms argument,
the constant clinical workers
who are afraid of have a problem,
they're afraid to do be a in fair enough [inaudible] but they're not nearly
enough of launching.
[inaudible] can feel better about change.
Jogging.
You feel way worse about [inaudible]
forgive
me the path
you would just discount this and maybe your retirement,
your boss,
it's made me bitter and cynical and resentful and cost are impressive and got
all of those where you go from there,
addicted,
violent,
and then work.
So it's like what do you frame it?
How nature interview early frame.
That one,
she free fat.
And that's [inaudible] bones,
right?
You don't want to be lulled into thinking that you've got an option in terms of
goal terror.
And so of we want to do is take your terror please to the right place.
We say the fear of God was the beginning of wisdom.
Right now,
I'm not making a religious cease to matter.
I don't think I'm brave
face.
And so the loose start started talking over in general for years goals because
about her,
even when I put my foot on the political now in Canada years ago,
each issue,
you know,
personally nervous,
I go to three anyway,
put asleep and I thought,
wow,
what's turned out in farming in the city in that regard,
we think we'll want to take the risk
with the alternative is to take out the risk,
which was to not say something.
It's like,
no,
I wasn't taking notes down as a worsened his plan,
a huge,
massive,
no separatism,
Tiernan free [inaudible] becoming worse because good people shop [inaudible]
well
okay,
we'll just refer to us just to get worse.
It's a real nabb [inaudible] early in the knock on effect because you've never
been,
well I didn't want to recall
turnoff.
So that's just one group.
We say,
well that's small,
like the outlaw,
which most social settings,
so
20 of
us.
I'm probably wrong because I'm assuming,
can you tell me
if you're in your apartment,
but at least to get you to say,
maybe we can offer a kit
[inaudible]
work as well,
where in the case if you think something,
the probability than most other people also thinking very hot,
a spectacular jeans and just absolutely original [inaudible].
You know,
it's hard to [inaudible] but anonymously,
so,
but other than that,
if you're a reasonable person face on,
everyone else is thinking too.
And just we'll say,
if you say,
well then maybe we'll say,
and you've been talking about convenience,
you know,
[inaudible] types of comedian because comedians to that whole entire Taiwanese
was thinking off,
say,
here's some of the whole thing.
And they're going to say,
can we say,
yeah,
the gesture a short term,
right?
Because he's the [inaudible] committee.
Here's what we're really about.
And everyone,
certainly me through life like that,
we have to be careful.
You have to be weighed.
You know,
if you're a reasonable person for thinking usable things that probably everyone
else has the suspicion that indicate soon so then they don't have to do anything
in forced silence.
So in crushing story we'll do it
[inaudible] here
at least in part,
the
profits that are critical for
the [inaudible].
I know I can't say I'm in the gym.
You can't listen
to the client.
Most of the people that are
[inaudible] as well [inaudible] that's the gym.
It's so much different than the front in the car.
You know,
we don't start through the door.
I can't assume Google.
As soon,
as soon as we go on a complete waste of space,
it's not battling with people,
which is one of
the downs.
If you allow something causing
increased the phone them and still and and do that in a team.
And so with my
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] said,
look,
just set it up and I have a series of images that you take that apart for
related stuff going on.
I didn't understand what the benefit can you clarify that seems to contradict.
You said minutes ago,
that's not an assault.
Just our Turner's.
He said,
hey,
I'm seeing nodding like we're going to,
so here's what I think you said that
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] to coach your
staff.
You know your agendas in your camper boots in the way disrupt describing color.
It's a really good step to allow your clause to there instead of manipulating
the world and the rules,
rules,
rules set up.
No,
I don't want her to succeed and if you've never meditated or
if [inaudible] to how,
and I'm going to do what's necessary in order to facilitate despite the fall.
Let's play that out and see what happens.
Then you listen to your staff and then those things will come to you and I do to
talk to you about that.
Rule check is the percentage of each species.
It's about the importance of aim.
If you eat
the higher up,
you wait.
The more the world receivable alliance and that,
this is the why that is.
That is the state of the most sophisticated neurosciences and the percentage.
That's how perceptions they Oregon.
The more we
stand on faith,
it's only going to be late.
He killed the last 50 years has come to a better conclusion.
Conclusion.
What would you see the world and the way you talk emotionally is the same time
you're going in fact Medicalese to determining now that see,
you know,
you could maybe not be practically at a counselor.
I'm not saying it's a panacea.
You know there's limits,
but fundamentally the world manifests itself in accordance with [inaudible] and
not [inaudible].
If it means that if you're not positioned properly in the world,
but the world was,
he would manage that.
We can tolerate.
If we bitter,
there's a high probability that you're aiming Raul [inaudible] sectors hosted
perfect origin,
criticize the world.
It's a miraculous fig.
It's true about an sequence teacher so that some,
because it couldn't be,
I really believe this.
This is a,
this is optimism.
That's the counterpart to the tracking [inaudible].
There's no better way to [inaudible] that works for you,
works for your family,
for your community.
It works for everything.
It works.
It's actually true.
So that's [inaudible] estrogen is actually the case.
[inaudible] are you worried about potential for teaching?
Give us some worried about
[inaudible]
first of all,
I have,
I have three sisters first and I would say a lot of them to be difficult.
And so that's given me a certain to perceptive.
Um,
there isn't anything in fame that give me more than our cows kill many important
ways.
Like I have a very good [inaudible],
you know,
be someone else but
because
of the
[inaudible]
family and my community and friends and so I'm not going to miss that because
that would be suited and John
[inaudible] at all.
So my family is very smart and the re re re re watching may have blooper for
quite a long time and there's stupid,
they get older,
you get the same thing.
It's super that we should be doing again.
Gail smart,
very much.
She this [inaudible] to Susan too many times that made you go well.
And so my thing,
I think I have 70 with maybe in a [inaudible] oriented and so we'll see.
But so far so good.
[inaudible]
I like to watch certain shows
or
Canadian.
That's why
you
ever seen the trailer park boys.
Oh my God,
Dude.
[inaudible]
talk about low brow.
Okay.
Oh,
so it was safe.
Oh
No,
it was the German war.
Um,
he,
I mean it was through [inaudible] not good.
So
there and we're trying don't have to do,
that's my whole
life.
There's
work
on the goals,
man.
Things are so much better.
For example,
I tell my
law,
which is what it was.
It's
like we hit,
that's a funny miracle.
That wasn't the case.
It
was lagging behind them assisting cash.
Nama hardly enough consequences of dissemination.
This tremendous Salvadorian community.
Suddenly technology putting a tremendous amount of power in the hands of
individuals.
And so that looks real good.
There's more horse to the northern answer and there wasn't a hundred years ago
you never even knew about now.
No.
One of the conferences are more carbon monoxide is in the world.
Won't get me for sending
you that will rectify department home entirely new level.
We have enough food for everyone.
And then I won't see.
You mentioned it was,
you know,
there's,
we have some,
we have some Finnish disorder on the relationship between the bowling,
but compared to start one,
that's a real problem.
And how,
you know,
he's waiting on fat people in the rural Starbucks [inaudible] I think each other
than healthspring Martin systems work,
we mentioned with the political systems can been celebrating some of the jewel
and those [inaudible] biological jewel scientific can feel old [inaudible] tale.